[Music]
everyone close your eyes you have your
eyes closed yep picture this picture
that you are the owner one trillion
dollars yeah why did Joe get all of it
I quit first [ __ ] how do you feel but
you're fired because I'm giving you
money I'm gonna private jet find
somewhere oh we stopped keeping our eyes
sorry it's cuz he jumped and I assumed
you Oliver I immediately skyrocketed
into revolutionising a nation and owning
it yeah it's eating something
yeah it's eating fish we're talking
about a kitten I I would not tell anyone
definitely not we're gonna find out as
soon as you freakin quit everything will
be like wait what happened I have a
trillion dollars your God at that point
you wouldn't lie to us you would tell us
yeah but I'm not I'm not nuts to the
rest of the world oh and then we're
gonna be like hello a few people but an
air one there's like one person I've
ever met
I wasn't asked I'm Abed nadir he just
gave me a billion 999 billion left if
they ask
I'll have an obstacle course that they
have to pass through and I'll be like if
you can survive this you can have
whatever you is your [ __ ] obstacle
course involved [ __ ] like sheep yeah
like shooting [ __ ] arrows and then a
big ball yeah and then I'll call it how
bad do you want it yeah it'll be a Tupac
remixed and I'll wrap it how bad do you
want it used to shoot an excuse for you
to rap again yeah probably go viral to a
trillion is a lot of money dude can you
believe that's an economy I wouldn't
care if you had a trillion anybody can
ask and you'll be like here you go here
you go but then they'll keep asking and
then it's also like that you won't run
out it's a trillion dollars dude it
really won't run out it depends on what
I would make them work for it so it
doesn't seem I think but it's a thousand
you can't even [ __ ] spend it all
still oh yeah donate some I'll do a lot
of different things but then also if
someone's like let me just get a billion
depending on who they are it's not like
if you just give time there's gonna blow
it the power get themselves killed but
isn't it funny to watch that and you
don't have to take care of them anymore
and then someone else about can I get a
billion that's only a thousand times so
you can't give a billion huh I think
it's only a thousand billions right yeah
that'll go by quick at me if you give a
thousand billions that's done give a
thousand dollars a billion times you
that's that's true a lot of times so
they are projecting that by 2026 we will
have the world's first trillionaire Jeff
bezels any other guesses that's what
that's what I read saw so my guess she's
not cutting down his money anytime soon
it's Jeff bezu by 2020 126 is growth is
still not at the peak that's why crazy
they're saying that he will be 62 years
old but Mark Zuckerberg will be there
saying that he Jack wall Stewart the
youngest Jack maza alien he can't die
he's most likely to be the youngest
trillionaire by 2037
well at the age of 51 Facebook is that
strong peaceful a growing exponentially
like that because but more people are
joining in man like not everyone still
not everyone's on Facebook yet no it's
not through Facebook he controls the
entire internet ads like anyone who
makes money through the internet goes
through Facebook you know what's crazy
in our generation we we did witness the
first billionaire right who was the
first billionaire want me to have people
back in the day but uh but like I feel
like we witnessed our first billionaire
and I thought we would we did not was
the first biblical fella yeah a
billionaire back then and he still holds
the title of history's wealthiest
individuals that's probably the trillion
Felician that's fine right come on
Julian with me you know what's funny
does it equal a trillion within oh yeah
I don't know you know what's funny back
then with all that money he still didn't
have air conditioning so [ __ ] that the
poor people here still [ __ ] live
better
than the rich people back there you know
what that makes me think so
when Casey and I were in Barcelona for
our honeymoon we stayed in this hotel
that you can clearly tell that in like
the 90s this was like the most upscale
hotel possible because of the decor like
the whole like buyers got style yeah I'm
like dude for sure in the 90s this [ __ ]
was poppin so I felt like I'm rich like
I get to experience the same [ __ ] that
rich 90 like in the 90s people get to
experience it's like when someone buys a
1992 Lexus and balling you just got a
time-warp yourself imagine 20 years ago
hell yeah Mercedes Benz diesel what
would you do with the train so there was
limited what he liked what was it let me
find this tweet again
you can't why not at this point if you
made a hundred eighty thousand dollars a
day from the day you were born
you still wouldn't be as rich as Jeff
Bezos yeah dude you know he makes two
thousand four hundred and eighty nine
dollars every second oh that's it people
better stop shopping on Amazon I'm
stopping for shirt I'm unsubscribing and
I'm gonna let everybody know his fortune
is so crazy I'm trying to get a five
chin though that's the average American
citizen spending one dollar is the
equivalent of him spending around 1.3
million dollars looking crazy that's
crazy
a million is a dollar to him yes yeah
how much of that he has in cash walking
because that's his net worth
yeah that's so different than some
people have a high net worth but when
you say in cash you mean also just in
the bank yeah that's so cash is like
liquid right so that's like always he's
swimming around in it yeah when you talk
about net worth
dude like it could be like I have this
company that's worth a billion dollars
but in my bank account I got three
dollars like Elon Musk when he sold
PayPal he was broke man you said [ __ ]
this all in on my new projects baby and
he lived in an apartment now look at him
though paid off baby and he got here I
don't know how he grew hair I respected
[Laughter]
I wish my hair would do that Rose using
like the shitty hairspray so like oh you
got the expensive [ __ ] now once he
started buying [ __ ] axe and [ __ ]
things started changing for him
yeah he just made it axe dude I feel
like Jeff Bezos gotta have at least a
hundred million liquid or 500 million
lip or he he's the world's first $100
billionaire like 100 billion in 100
billion yeah but you know what we all
here drink and eat like billionaires
because guess what a Coca Cola for us is
the same as a Coca Cola for them a
bottle of water for us is the same as
them preach so guess what we all live
like billionaires here baby the caviar
that we eat so eloquently I never afford
so easily it's the same to them I never
I never experienced a fee as a pilot
plane air is you if you go on an
airplane do this put on some
[ __ ] headphones next [ __ ] you
go to sleep if you would come like that
is the same as getting a massage [ __ ]
to everyone it's like what's the point
you're sleeping on the flight 8008
mm-hmm but then I did see some private
planes though you got a full-on bed and
all that and I was kind of jealous yeah
you know the rock gets a haircut on his
flight on his plane there's any like
steak or something with fork and knife
or we don't even get a fork and knife my
knife in the air in theory yeah but he
has his own private jet and then and
there cutting his hair and he's eating
but you know what when your life is so
busy like when we experience this right
like we were buying more guns than we
actually went to go shoot that year yeah
well like when you're in that position
do you have time to slow down to enjoy
what's going on or everything is just so
fast-paced then you're just running
through everything and not really
getting the full enjoyment look at the
negative side you might be running
through
he cheated on his wife the rock did or
how much like thirty billion dollars
he's still destined to be the first
trillionaire even giving that money he
still made money yeah they were saying
that if just Jeff Bezos net worth does
reach a trillion he will be worth more
than the individual of GDPs of 179
countries with a combined population of
3.4 billion forty three point seven
percent of all humans alive to date I
wonder if his security is crazier than
like the president it must be he's a
country dude especially Democrats hate
him
especially now that like an Amazon what
were you telling me earlier oh yeah so
he's also like because of this way more
rich and on track to becoming the first
trillionaire faster because the corona
buys the corner virus oh yeah and
everything [ __ ] up has helped his
business like crazy
lousy paying people less he's cutting
their hazard pay I think at the end of
May
yeah all these crazy things and then he
he ended up selling [ __ ] son of his
shares and then he became 3.4 billion
dollars richer alright he done a lot of
it and he did this before everything
happened so he probably heard what's
happening in China he's like I'm a
[ __ ] sell all this [ __ ] and i'ma buy
a back baby at a cheaper rate I don't
care how rich he is he's busted I don't
care he's [ __ ] bus I don't know you
see the old picture of him when he's
like all geeky and cocky means less he
looks better now no bald-headed Jack and
everything hey but it's trillion dollars
is still a trillion dollars and there's
really good-looking ladies that don't
give a [ __ ] I mean yeah I'm like how do
you have this face and you're thinking
you're a winner I think when you have
that face you work hard to be worth that
but yes most of these guys are ugly as
[ __ ] look at this let me face with a
cute kitten
damnit trillion he's on his way to
looking like mr. burns though you know
who could play him cater there's like a
Kevin Spacey Ronit Bonner you know he's
got cerebral palsy look at half of his
eyes in shape Bell's palsy
man if I was that ballin I would only I
would always fly in planes I would have
one plane pull the other plane and the
other plane is even on there's another
just like the [ __ ] float in the back
the first time I would just make
anything come to me I would even go
anyway but if he's so cheap do you think
he's even splurging cuz I heard he's
[ __ ] cheap well I feel you have to be
like gonna be smart
I'm sure you I'm sure his cheap is also
his cheap is a different level of cheap
chill yeah he's that guy only bought a
[ __ ] me only bought five five jets
you know he just sneezed on a whole roll
of toilet paper and throw the whole cat
I think we use individual squares at
this point dough do you think he has
assassins and [ __ ] oh yeah cuz I'm
scared at that point yeah man somebody
has people checking his food guy has his
own army so the Amazon army and for sure
like how much he's like if those people
are like helping fund the government's
and like the government best two-year
well if he's like oh this is another guy
that could like take over my business
get him gone I want to see his daily
routine you wanna see his dick that too
but I want to see his daily routine I
want to see what kind of like when he
wakes up how he works what he's doing is
he in meetings like I want to see if he
ever just kicks back on the bed and goes
on Instagram on offense does is it that
you just want to see it so you can go
all thank god I don't want a trillion
dollars cuz this is what the price I
have to pay is that what no judgment I
just really want to see if he just place
like any app games or like if he has any
side things that he does I think for
like even him I think he just did
everything smart and create something
that was like needed because for sure
Gary Vee over works himself harder than
Jeff Bezos Jerry be still building but
he's building doing all that stuff I
only like he likes building he likes it
that's this man's going to space so in
terms of working and stuff like that I
don't like I'm sure if you like meetings
and stuff it's like on a crazy level but
it's not like some teams now it's not
about how hard you worked
Jerry these point buying his programs
and learning from him the show yes I
want to see how efficient he is or how
what he does and I want him to try like
bullying pretzels and he's like enjoying
other parts of life like to get to where
he isn't to get to where he's going he's
just working oh that's why it brings him
enjoyment yeah I mean like that's why I
said other parts of life like he's got
that one thing and he's still going he
just does what the [ __ ] he wants yeah
cuz he's like to be a few I would have
quit by then for sure after a couple
billion I would have quit at like 10
million dude you know I want to quit
tomorrow and I don't even got that money
I just talked right now how could
tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]